- Super bars.
(recorder mumbles)
Cool.
Yo what's up everybody,
make sure you hit subscribe.
You're missing out on so
many fuckin' jewels and gems,
and they're fucking free.
Stop paying for dumb shit.
Start subscribing to smart shit.
(intro music)
You got your perspective.
I just want to be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(music plays)
People always say they're gonna do shit.
The biggest epidemic,
in the world is people talking not doing.
And especially now, and
people always do that.
But now what social media
does is expose people,
it doesn't change people.
All the hate in the
system, that's exposing.
Twitter didn't make you evil, you're evil.
You know, and same with
talking and not doing.
Twitter, Instagram,
didn't make you waste time
and not do.
Don't like delete your app off your phone
and think you're being productive now.
That's the byproduct of
what's going on here.
You're just gonna watch TV instead.
You're just gonna play Fortnite instead.
You're just gonna go to coffee shops,
and make pretend you're working instead.
People always talk.
(music plays)
Dude think about me dude,
you know this truth, like I talk all day,
and yet I talk about, blabber.
Four things, like I'm
doing a million things.
We're doing a million things.
(airline speaker sounds)
I'm doing at all times.
Like really, really, really.
No, because they don't matter.
Because those are,
those are small details in the game.
That's like somebody
who's not six foot two,
and can throw the ball 80 yards,
watching YouTube videos on
how to be a quarterback,
that's just a waste of fucking time.
People are just wasting time.
Lack of self awareness.
'Cause people wish they
could be doing something,
instead of focusing on what they can do.
Right? I wish I could be like Ninja,
and play Fortnite.
I wish I could be like Lebron.
I wish I could be like Lil Uzi Vert.
I wish I could be like Gary V.
Right? I never wished I
could be like anybody.
I just focused on who I was,
and I became Gary V.
I'm not trying to be somebody else.
Self awareness is the
unlock to actually doing.
Closing your ears and not hearing doubt,
speeds up the process of execution,
because you're not in a place where you're
slowing down and valuing
other people's opinions.
Patience allows you to run in perpetuity
and not over judge yourself,
because it hasn't happened
in the first six months.
That's the fucking formula.
Super bars.
(music plays)
- Killing it.
- Thanks Phil.
- What's up man? Donny.
- Your birthday's November 14th?
- It is.
- So is mine.
- That's what's up.
- Scorpios in the house.
Right on Gary.
- It's nice to meet you.
- It's nice to meet you brother.
- Take care.
What's up brother?
- How are you man?
Great to see you.
- Good to see you bro.
- Hi, good to see you,
thanks for coming again.
- Good to be here.
How we feeling?
- Phenomenal, so I know you know that
it was in this building last year, right?
- Yep.
- We doubled capacity,
with this entire building as well.
The brand is on super hard.
Everybody's invested 10 times on what
their build outs are.
The amount of staff, their infrastructure,
sales training, and
all that kind of stuff,
specifically for the show to take orders.
They've been booking appointments,
all that kind of shit.
So it's getting very, very real
for a lot of these guys.
- We haven't been attacked.
It's against the terms of service.
So you wer-
like and it's an important mindset,
like right there that's
the most important part.
'Cause you weren't, you were trying to,
you know what the rules are.
You were trying to get your benefit,
so the question becomes,
you know, what do you do about that.
Over long term, I think
those rules will ease up.
Kinda like what happened
with me with liquor.
In the short term, is it influencers?
Is it starting your own podcast?
You know, like too many people,
in the Cannabis game right now,
crying that they can't do shit
on Facebook and Instagram,
specifically Instagram.
I cry that I can't drive 250
miles an hour on the highway.
So I think people need
to be smart about that.
Once you make that switch,
you spend no time crying about that.
You're trying to start another account,
and then get caught again.
Then you start trying to
figure out other solutions.
- Yeah, no man, I really appreciate that.
- Yeah man.
Look, being best always
plays out in the end.
It just takes longer.
- Yeah.
True.
- You understand?
- Keep at it, yeah.
- Yeah, I mean think
right now in this world,
where everyone's like
such in a rush, right?
Just you know, in a rush for success.
Like if you've really got those advantages
and it's something that
you've always been into
before it was cool, what have you.
- Yeah.
- You just play it out and
just run that marathon.
- Do you have any advice
for me right now man?
- I do.
40 of the first 50
speeches I gave were free.
- Amen, I've been doing them.
- And then the market will speak.
- Right, if I'm good or not.
- You know it's like a band,
it's like a comedian, it's like a rapper.
You got to do shows, you got to do shows.
- Right I'm doing it.
- You got to get raps.
At first, nobody knew who the fuck I was.
- Right.
- Nobody knew who ET was.
- Everybody knows now.
Appreciate you man.
Let me get a selfie real quick.
- Yeah of course.
- Thank you so much for everything you do.
- Thank you bro.
- God bless you.
- Damien Posey, uncle Damien's speech,
watch for me man, I'll be coming.
I'll do what you've been
telling me to do man.
- Keep doing it bro.
- Early in the morning, trolling,
talking like getting upset.
Not trolling, but you know.
- Bringing value.
- Bringing value to the comments.
- God bless you.
- Thank you bro.
- If you wanna come through,
eight people in a little crammed-
that's the kind of shit I love.
- A little garage,
Do you have any advice or any-
- Honestly, the advice is real
simple for dudes like you.
Like literally, literally,
the core thing that I keep pushing,
'cause I believe in it the most,
is patience.
So many people could be successful,
the problem is they're
trying to get their so fast,
they cheat and then they lose.
Not super complicated.
It's really not.
It's like, everybody's so like,
passionate of looking successful,
that it fucks them up from
actually being successful.
- Absolutely.
- You know, like-
- Or based out of Sacramento, too,
where a lot of business
happening, a lot of the-
- Dude, it's happening,
dude it's happening every-
you mean this space?
- Sort of, for California.
- Yeah, yeah.
I think that's right.
Yeah, I think that's right.
But like honestly, it's
gonna happen everywhere.
- Absolutely.
- We gotta? Okay.
You know, it's happening everywhere.
It's nice to meet you.
Yeah I'd love to see.
I love that shit dude.
You're right, you pegged me.
Like that's-
Like I'm kinda fantasizing of like
moving to another country
and starting from the beginning.
Just 'cause the beginning's
my favorite part.
It's the process, it's the process.
And that's honestly
the same point of like,
it's easy for me to be patient,
because I like playing more than
I like the thing's that playing gives me.
- Yeah.
- And everybody wants the stuff that
playing gives them.
People want cars and boats
and houses and girls.
And it's the same shit.
And in a world, where like
everybody's in their feed,
seeing everybody else doing it,
it just gets very fucking like Meta.
- Expensive watches, and Yeezys right?
- That's right.
And like, it's hard to
build a real business.
And like something that's
meaningful, you know?
And like.
I'm going with this guy to
Quitar for like five minutes.
- Literally 5 minutes,
he's flying in and flying out at night.
- Ah, you've done that.
- Yeah I know, I love it.
You were my admin when I did Kuwait city?
- Yeah in 24 hours.
- When you were scared that I was
gonna go to jail for cursing?
- Oh, because you couldn't curse,
it was illegal to curse and I'm googling-
I'm getting flagged on Google 'cause
how do you get out of Kuwaiti jail.
How else am I gonna find out?
- What up my boy?
- What up, bro.
- Yeah, I fucking love you dog.
- Thank you bro.
- You mind if I get a
picture with you bro?
Let me get a picture with him too,
this guy dude.
- I listen to you every single day.
- Every day.
Literally like three
subscriptions on my podcast,
and you're one of them.
- Thank you bro, I appreciate that.
- Yo shoutout Gary V.
- We're here, we're fucking here.
- Yo, we made it.
We made it, dap it up.
- You're the man Gary, I
appreciate you brother.
- Thanks for the love guys.
- Hey can, I'll get one real quick.
Sorry bro, I have to.
- How are you guys?
Whaddup bro?
- Can I get a selfie with you?
- You got it bro.
Nice to meet you, you got it.
How are you?
- Good I'm Janelle.
- Janelle, nice to meet you.
- Thank you!
- So nice to meet you.
- Dude look.
(laughter)
- How are you?
- How you doing man?
- Real well, yeah sure.
- I have to, you don't understand,
you don't understand.
- I appreciate it.
- It's like you speak from my soul.
So it's one of those moments.
Can you please?
I'm so groupie ing right-
- Is this all like weed in things?
- No no, it's all-
- No, yeah this is all just real food.
- Wait this bread had weed in it?
- Oh yeah sorry.
Never tried it, huh?
- Last time I was there,
like here last year, I was like
I'm gonna get caught on something.
I'm always nibbling shit, you know.
- The thing that I'm
noticing about our kids
is they don't understand that failure is a
part of success.
(inaudible mumbling)
Like not understanding that.
Like all these failures you go through
is some learning curve for you.
- It's because failure is demonized
in our current culture, unfortunately.
That's just not how
parents raise these kids.
Like I would watch these kids growing up
in my school system were kids with,
their parents would look at them like
you're a failure, you're never
gonna get past where I did.
And you can't make the
basketball team, give up.
Why would you do it next year?
- Parents use kids as
their own self esteem.
Parents care about what
other parents think,
not what their kids think.
- Exactly.
- That's the problem.
It's one big game of insecurity.
One big fucking game of insecurity, bro.
It's what it is.
It's all it is.
We could educate self esteem.
If I could, I'd rather, I'd rather
somebody not know how to do anything,
and have self esteem,
than know how to do everything
and have no self esteem.
Self esteem, I mean that's the underlying,
like the underlying thing
I'm doing with my content.
Is giving all those kids,
somebody to point to as the
permission to do something.
That's all I'm doing.
I'm creating one big game of permission,
that if they fail, they
can tell their parents
Gary told them to do it.
Like I'm willing to be that shield.
- Blame it all on me.
- Blame it on me.
That's why I go so hard on parents issues.
That's why I go so hard at this.
Gary told me not to go to college.
What? Hello?
Mr. Garfield how are you?
Yeah sorry bro, like what?
Like I'm not worried about their
fucking parents yelling at me.
I wasn't worried at my
own parents yelling at me.
How am I gonna be worried
about somebody else's?
- We have a problem on
the Indian reservations,
and it's important, education is important
to an extent right?
We get to that point where
it's pushed so much that,
and these kids don't understand it,
that they just decide to quit.
They decide to go be part of the system,
rather than pushing on with the education,
because it's pushing on them so hard.
Like for me, I wouldn't
got off the reservation
if it wasn't for the Marine Core.
Because I had to choose
to make that choice,
because it was get out,
it was fight or flight.
You know, I was either gonna stay there
and fight for my very life,
because half the kids
I went to high school
with are dead now.
So where would I be today?
Or go-
- And why are they dead?
Where, like how-
- Alcoholism, suicide, and drug addiction.
We have the highest rate
of suicide amongst kids.
I'm talking 18 year olds and younger.
My two cousins-
- Is that a poverty issue?
Is that a-
- It's a poverty issue,
it's a self esteem issue.
'cause to me it's like they
see things on social media,
and their life doesn't mirror that.
'cause it's true, dirt floors,
walking outside to use the bathroom in
the middle of South Dakota.
- But to your point,
like the thing that really matters,
like look no television didn't give them
images either, right?
Like the current state
is your Instagram feed.
It used to be MTV cribs.
It's all the same shit.
It's either you're good
with what you've got
or you're not.
It's either that you've got FOMO of
what somebody else has or not.
You know, which is why it needs to become
an insular game.
- And so we have these
kids that see this stuff-
- The thi-, you know I apologize,
but you've got me-
the thing that, you know, the
thing that you said to me,
and which means that we both understand.
Our humble beginnings is our strength.
We have to-
My big thing with the internet is like,
so when I came up, I'm 43,
when I came up in the business world,
because I'm such a shit student,
and I didn't come from the right pedigree,
I didn't go to Harvard or
I didn't go to McKinsey.
I was considered to have
no chance of success.
Like flat out.
Like that was just the rules of the game.
These kids, the kids in
dirt floors right now
in South Dakota on an Indian reservation,
the internet allows them
to actually have a chance.
- It does, it does.
- And so my big thing is I now believe,
that the have-nots,
actually have a bigger advantage,
because they think the haves,
are entitled and soft.
And actually more macro insecure.
Like the kid who's got the best passes
to Coachella, and a BMW and their parents
bought their way in to a great college.
They're hurting inside.
More than people realize.
'Cause they actually lose.
No matter what, no
matter what they achieve,
they didn't achieve it.
Their parents put them on.
Us, the we suck,
and we- studio apartment
six family members,
dirt floor.
But if we achieve it's us.
And with this..
Yeah real pleasure, real pleasure.
Thank you bro.
Thank you so much.
- The clip, sure sure.
We can walk.
Just got out of a fun conversation.
We're trying to do this,
a little more context up front,
to what you're about to see.
You know, there's always
a connection point I have
when I meet somebody else
from the virtual dirt floor.
There's a sense of the people that
most understand what
I'm saying are the one
who have lived what I've lived.
And the things that you're gonna see here
are an amazing unlock.
And we are living through this world,
where people that have too little,
for the first time ever,
have more of an advantage,
than the people that have too much.
I genuinely actually believe that.
I think over the next 50 years, 100 years,
like that will play out,
through the way we viewed
the human behavior,
over this next last century.
So, I hope you enjoy this clip.
- So we've got like an hour,
an hour and ten minutes to
walk you through all of this.
- How are you?
- Good man, I feel like I've
known you for a long time.
From the videos and the content, yeah.
- Thank you.
- Hey Gary, Eric Jennings.
- Eric, such a-
And does that make you feel good?
- Yeah. Like you like the high?
Hey bub!
- How are you, good to see you.
- How'd your talk go?
- It was good, this is Ben my partner,
I don't know if you've ever met him.
- Such a pleasure.
It's good to see you Bob,
I'll talk to you soon.
- Yeah honestly for me it's more like-
- Hey Gary, my name's Tony.
- Pleasure.
- Hey I fucking love you.
- Thank you bro.
- For real bro, I appreciate you bro.
- I got sober four years ago,
and because of you I'm still
fucking alive today homie.
That shit in the beginning,
meant the fucking world to me dog.
I want you to know that.
I'm from the grass roots here.
Went to prison for this plant,
I still run a podcast about
the fucking grass roots.
It wasn't for you in the beginning dog,
straight up I'd be back
in prison today, homie.
- Fuck bro, thank you so much
for sharing that with me.
That means a lot to me.
- I mean that, it means the
fucking world to me dog.
You, Andy, and all you motherfuckers,
you kept me fucking going.
- Thank you bro.
- And now I'm trying to cultivate people
just like you are,
and I'd love to get you on
the show one day if I could.
- Hit me up, it's done.
It's a lock.
You DM me and tell me your story,
I'll get it locked in.
- Successful cannabis catering business,
on Instagram, because of you,
and from watching you
and you've inspired me.
- And I'm fucking so-
- Thank you bro, whaddup everybody.
- And I listen to a lot
of shit that you say bro,
and I've changed my life,
on some real shit bro,
leveled the fuck up bro.
- That's what's up.
- So, Mike, I missed your talk last year
What are you talking about this year man?
You haven't figured it out yet?
- You've got me pegged, I have no clue.
- Man big time fan.
- Thank you bro.
Hi.
- How you doing?
- Very well, how are you?
- I'm a really big fan.
- Thank you.
It's so nice to meet you.
- The thing I love about you,
is that you don't give no fucks.
- Zero.
- Me too, we're on the same team.
- That's awesome, so nice to meet you.
- Right on.
- What's your name?
- I'm Sway, from the bay.
- Such a pleasure, nice to meet you.
Hi brother, it's great to see you bro.
- I just texted you, I don't know if that-
- Dude I did a food and wine festival
in the Jet Stadium with this dude
when he was at CAA.
This is good fucking people.
- He has that to do, but
also a million other things.
- It doesn't matter with that,
he's killing the entire cycle.
- Got it.
- I have a million things to do too.
But if I'm sitting with
disproportional amounts
of IP, that's detrimental to scale.
Then I'm creating a vulnerable business.
- So would you say that his job
right now is to focus on product?
And make sure we all understand
that more than anything else?
- Oh a hundred percent.
- Okay.
- A hundred percent.
- But then if he does that-
- [Woman] That's what I said!
- This is Chelsea by the
way, she's on our team,
she's a huge fan as well.
- I'm listening, because I'm like
I just got onto the team,
and I'm like this is exac-
- We just hired Chelsea.
- That's exactly what has to happen.
Some of the other stuff will be slower.
But like, you're running a marathon.
Everybody's so caught up in quick results,
yes that's the answer.
- Taco Bell was my
hangout spot right there,
- That's amazing.
- The original one over
in Springfield there.
- Nice to meet you, pleasure.
- Two years in a row man.
- Thank you brother.
Here that's who I was looking for.
What up bro?
You well?
- Yeah just chilling, living.
See you out here still killing it.
- Trying, trying.
Sup bro, good to see you.
Thank you man.
- I just wanted to say hi.
- You well?
- Yeah, just out here living.
(laughing)
- No we've never met,
but I love you brother.
I love everything you push
out man, you're awesome.
- Thank you brother.
- I haven't bought
(inaudible word), but I will.
I had to be honest with you, you know.
- I appreciate it.
- Bunch of bullshitters out
there, I got you though.
- Thank you bro, take care.
- Love the videos man.
- Thank you bro, I appreciate that.
- Have you guys met before James?
- James, how are you?
Good to see you.
The internet.
I pay attention.
- Eric, Gary, real quick.
- Yeah how you doing man?
- A legend, good to see you, yeah.
- Thank you for everything.
- I'm a little (inaudible word) of you.
- I know you are.
- In a tiny little way.
- Yeah, I know you are.
- Super affordable, one strain,
who cares what the name is,
'cause that doesn't matter to anyone.
Unless you live in California.
And just affordable,
and I made all the crap.
Like literally, even shop off my store,
up right now, you can buy this stuff from.
And it's like, you want shitty sunglasses
you can lose, perfect.
You want the worst lighter of all time?
We'll sell it to you.
Like it's bad on purpose.
- No I get it.
- Even the design-
- No I think it's right.
- Even bad on purpose.
This is Sean. Gary.
- Sean. Real pleasure.
- Good to see you brother.
- I just wanted to say hi.
- Hi!
- That's my brand.
- It's amazing.
- I just wanted to meet you.
- Thank you, what's your name?
- Rebecca.
- Nice to meet you Rebecca.
Thanks for saying what's up.
Is that a Jets jersey bro?
- Yes, yes it's a Jets jersey.
- That's what's up bro.
- I have a delivery service out here too/
But I also do vintage on the side man.
I found this jersey.
- Neil O' Donnell, that's what's up.
- And I was like I need
to get it to Gary man,
when I see him man.
- That's amazing bro.
- So this is my gift to you my man.
- Thank you bro.
- And you are the biggest
part of my life man,
you changed my life, for real.
So I would love a picture with you man.
- Of course.
I didn't catch your name.
- Steven, man.
- Steven, thank you. Thank you so much.
- Derock I don't wanna lose that.
Good to see you, how you been?
- Doing well, hanging in there.
- How's the show been?
- It's been really good.
This is what we're working with.
- Dude this is like,
you know what's crazy,
like literally the parallels
to the wine business,
always fuck with me so heavily.
- You need some sommeliers
up in this shit.
(laughing)
- By the way, it's a hundred per-
I promise you, on the
fucking video record.
There will be, a person that reviews this,
in eleven years, that
everybody listens to.
And at first everyone's
gonna love her or him,
but then they're gonna
have too much power.
And everyone's gonna hate them.
That's exactly what happened
in the wine business.
- I wanna thank you, because
I used your 10 minute
you and Tony Robins, on my kids,
Who are graduating from college,
high school sorry, and
about to go to college
and billions is there favorite show.
And so they both wanna do-
- Yep, I get it.
- They're achievers, they're doers.
And they wanna figure out
how to do the stock market.
And I said alright, but before you do it,
I want you to watch this.
And it turned the lights on
for them, so it was awesome.
It was literally last week.
- That makes me happy, good to see you.
Of course, that's the real shit.
- I was just talking to them about like-
- Superstar.
- The best. Incredible.
- You been well?
- I'm doing great.
I just have to say one
thing, don't hate me for it.
- You're a Patriots fan.
- I'm a lifelong Pat-
- I literally knew,
literally knew where you were going.
The only thing that people ever-
- I mean Steve Grogen.
I mean 'cause I'm old.
- That feels better.
- All the way back to-
- Jim Plunkett like that stuff.
- You know, I love Plunkett 'cause he was
a California quarterback, but it was also
when I wasn't cheering for,
I also liked the early Raiders.
- I get it, Andre Tippett,
Stanley Morgan those guys.
- But, Plunkett won the Superbowl,
it was incredible, it was incredible.
I love those early-
- Literally I knew you
were gonna say that,
that's the only thing that
people ever hedge with
like don't hate me.
- You should claim the New York Times
for that story, they're gonna be like okay
I'm not just (inaudible words) the Jets.
That's great though.
- Real pleasure bro.
I was talking to these
guys about leveling up
what we're doing together and
we're gonna have a proper meeting soon.
There's nothing more fun
than watching the maturation
of a segment or genre,
like growing up in the
social media revolution
was a lot of fun.
When you knew, before anybody else knew,
same shit with this.
- Hey Mr. V.!
- What up bro, it's so good to see you.
- Always a pleasure to see you.
- How you feelin?
- I'm great.
- I love you.
- I love you too.
- Hello.
- Hello, I'm Carla.
- Carla, Gary.
- Nice to meet you.
- What you doing out here Mr. V.?
- My company owns a
piece of this conference.
- Oh wow!
- I'm in this, I was here last year.
I'm speaking at 6:00.
- Oh wow.
- How you feeling?
- I'm great.
- When'd you get in?
- I got in last night.
On Sunday night and we drove here.
- Pretty amazing right?
- Amazing, I heard it was
bigger than it was last year.
- Oh yeah it's like-
- But this is amazing.
- You been well?
- I've been very well.
- I've been following all your content,
I'm paying attention.
- And I follow all your content,
and you done woke me out of so many
dark, dark day brother.
- Like I told you when you came through,
like hit me any time.
- Yes sir, I know you moving.
- You know when you DM
me, I'm always replying.
- I know you do, and that's
why I love you so much.
Because as busy as this guy is,
he still takes the time
to hit me directly.
- You're a fucking legend bro.
You're a legend bro.
- He is.
- Get over here.
Hit me up if you need me.
- I will, thank you Mr.V..
- I'll see you soon,
I'll see you back East.
- Can we take a little
picture right quick?
- Of course.
It's great to see you bro.
- I appreciate it man, yeah you too.
- Take care of yourself.
- We're gonna make a B
line back to countercraft.
- My marketing guy, he's
a huge fan of yours.
- Thank you bro, tell
him I said thank you.
Thank you, it means a lot to me.
- What's up guys?
How you doing man?
I love your videos.
- Thank you bro, thanks
for saying that man.
- Remember Justin?
- Of course.
I remember every good looking dude.
I look at every good
looking dude I remember.
How are you bro?
- Things are good,
thanks for saying hello.
- You look like you could be brothers,
it cracks me up.
- I literally just told
him he's so good looking,
that was like a huge compliment.
I literally said that to him.
Literally, that's what I said,
I feel so good now.
- Thanks for saying what's up.
- Yeah, no problem man.
- See what happens though,
bro I fucking love you bro.
- Thank you bro.
- Straight up dude.
- I appreciate that.
What's your name bro.
- Mitch.
- Mitch. I appreciate the love bro.
Thank you so much.
- Keep doing it.
- I'm trying.
It's such a pleasure,
congrats on all your success.
- We were so excited to see you speak.
- Thank you.
- I was like wait, maybe we should follow
him to his speech.
- What up family?
You killed it the other night.
- Oh man, thank you man.
- I saw that come through bro.
- How's it been going here?
- Pretty good.
- You been with these guys?
- Yes, yes. Al!
Alex!
- Yeah I just said what's up to him.
- This is my partner Al man.
- How long have you guys known each other?
- Three years now.
- That's what's up,
I'm really glad you guys
are talking to Green Tree.
You guys are talking.
So this is my man Joe.
Joe worked with Vander
media for nine years.
I flew him out here to L.A.,
and runs Green Screen, which is like
our marketing company
in the Cannabis space.
That's what we're doing.
We own a piece of this conference.
- You're a bad, bad man.
- Quietly, quietly.
And that event the other night,
you guys really did it.
I was pissed I didn't go.
You enjoyed it?
I could see you did, you know?
- It was a-
- Yeah that was some heartfelt shit.
That's what's up.
- Hey buddy.
- It's great to see you again.
- How you doing?
- Congrats on everything,
this setup is busy as shit.
Congrats on the deal.
- Yeah, I know let's do this.
- Post Malone brand.
- Yep.
- And on the right hand side will cookies,
Burner might be there.
- Sup bro, how are you?
- I came to this last year,
and I thought it was really cool,
so I thought it was important that I-
- Launch here.
- Do something here, yeah.
- How long you been on with us?
- Well we took these
pictures four years ago.
- How long you been on this project?
- Two, three weeks, four weeks.
- Get the fuck out of here.
What Austin called you?
- We started this about one week ago.
Hi buddy, how are you doing?
You happy or what?
- I love this kid.
- He sent me a photo and I remade it.
And then Austin didn't like it of course.
- So we made a 3D render
and it's got like-
- Dude how good does this look though?
Its exactly what you sent me.
- Its exactly what we sent you.
- How are you?
- Proud of you guys, so good.
Dude this is such a good look.
- Do you wanna sit?
- Yeah.
Such a good look.
Same with me like, like the shit I-
like people are like "Oh, fuck".
I was like yeah oh fuck nothing,
like the shit I-
- Yeah no you're right.
- The shit I learned in a flea market
- Like yeah we've been
at this for three years.
- Exactly.
- I didn't do this exact thing,
but I did 10 other things
that are close to it.
- You know what's crazy,
you see all those pictures on Instagram,
where it's like icebergs,
or everyone goes that's easy.
Like that shit is real.
- A hundred percent, a hundred percent.
- Like decisions I'm
making today on business,
is something I learned
negotiating at a flea
market when I was 11.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- Merchandising and the
position of your plants,
I saw Tulips like out of a truck-
- I believe in that shit bro.
I believe in that shit.
- Same, same thing.
- It makes me happy you guys
are winning man, for real.
I really enjoyed meeting you guys,
back at the office that day.
- What's team liquid?
- It's an Esports team that's super fresh.
One of your dudes on your
company peeped it-
- Yeah, probably Bobby.
- Yeah, he knew it.
- He loves Esports.
- He knew it, he knew it.
Give him love.
- It's been going well?
- Yeah its been a good sh-
- Nice to meet you, I love your talk.
- Thank you.
- Such a great upbringing and
hearing behind your story.
Where you came up from
is amazing, amazing.
- Thank you.
- Ready 1,2,3.
- Thank you for saying hello.
Hi.
- Hi, how are you.
- Love over everything.
(chatter)
Thank you brother.
- Good to see you.
- Hi, good to see you, how are you?
You well?
- I'm trying.
- Still from that video,
you know, I mean I post that
video every three months.
- I know, I know, I'm still terrified.
- In your own head.
- Yeah, but i think maybe I'm-
- But less, but less.
- I think I'm embracing
that I'm maybe just a
behind the scenes person,
operator, crusher, executor.
- Well that is a very, very thoughtful,
like that's great.
To your point, not everybody's gotta
be in front of the camera.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But even when you're behind the scenes,
when you value their fucking opinions,
it's still gonna fuck you up.
You're still gonna have somebody,
either that works for you,
parallel to you, or that you work for.
So, just because you're behind the scenes,
the thing I told you,
on stage last year is
the most single truth.
You have to be in your own fucking head.
You can't value their opinions.
- I know.
- You can respect them,
but they can't trump yours.
- Day by day you just gotta keep-
- Chip chip, you're so young its practice.
- I know, it is practice.
- You ever have friends
reach out to you when
that video went, got put-
- Gary, thank you, I had so much support
from people I didn't even know,
sending me emails like,
it's comforting, you know,
to know that people-
- Care!
- Can relate, because sometimes you feel
like you're the only one.
But there's plenty of people out there
that want to make content and are equally-
- Scared.
- Just figuring it out.
- Yeah, one hundred percent.
- When did you start making content?
You were like in your 30's.
- When I was 30, yeah,
when I was 31 years old,
I started the wine show in like,
and you know it wasn't as heavy back then,
nobody thought it would even do well.
Now its like there's an expectation so,
exactly right, such a long process.
- You just put it out
and just kept doing it.
- My big thing is when I put it out,
I'm already satisfied, so
I don't need the likes,
I don't need the comments,
and I don't need the judgment.
So, that's the framework
I'm trying to push
for people at least, to
debate that perspective.
Because it makes it a
hell of a lot more fun.
- Well you know what's funny?
You posted something a
couple days later like,
that you, when you post
somebody who's afraid,
then the expectation gets really high.
And then you get more afraid.
Like you wanna become a
perfectionist at that point.
- That's right.
Its all the same, like
the themes are so consistent.
You either pander to the FOMO,
you pander to other people's opinions.
You pander to last time I got 55 likes.
And why did this one only get 33?
- Do I look stupid?
- What are they thinking?
What do they really think?
- Was that a good caption?
Its wild.
So, it was good to see you.
- Its great to see you again.
Take care.
- I just want to like thank you,
for everything that you do for people.
'Cause you're like seriously awesome.
I started listening to you when I was like
really getting on my hustle.
I'm 22 and I'm like really
trying to make my way in the industry.
And like have my own
investments and businesses,
and like I just love your cut throatness.
I love you who you are and I just like
wanted to say thank you for who you are.
- Thank you McKenzie, thanks for the love.
- Of course, do you smoke at all?
- I don't.
- Okay, well here's this if
you wanna give it to anybody.
- Thank you, I will.
- But I really appreciate it.
- Thank you, so nice
you meet you, take care.
This is for you, Phil.
How are you bro?
It makes sense to me, 'cause
of the world I come from,
in the wine business, and so
- Its very analogous.
- I fully understand what you're up to.
- Yeah, hell yeah.
- And I think its one
of the right approaches
to the model in this industry.
- Yeah, but we're not doing
our own retail either.
So, it's like we're living-
- What up big dog?
- Yo, I've been watching everything
you've been doing on Instagram.
'Cause I've been following you a lot,
YouTube videos, the whole nine, I've
seen you question everybody.
But, what I'm saying to that is,
I've followed you for 11 years.
Started in the industry,
I left California.
Went to Colorado, basically I just
got up and did it myself.
Stop bullshitting, I'm
the director of operations
of one in Oakland California now.
Four cultivations, one dispensary brother.
Just wanted to tell you I still keep
you on the Instagram.
Much love, I love everything.
- What's your name?
- Joe Ohmer, man.
- Joe Ohmer, real pleasure Joe.
- Pleasure man, can I
get a picture with you?
- A hundred percent.
- Here, here.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Appreciate it.
- Hi!
- Hi.
- I'm Nancy!
- Nancy.
- I was literally manifesting to
run into you somewhere.
I was like we have to run-
- That literally happened, I'm David.
- The way you preach,
it's so inspirational.
- Thank you.
- Like for someone like myself
building a brand right now,
it's exactly what I need all the time.
Whenever I get knocked down,
or whenever I have any doubt, I'm like
fuck it, fuck it.
- That's real, right?
Nobody's gonna cry for us, you know?
- Let me get a photo of you two.
- I just gotta say dude,
I wish that more people
were posting the positivity.
- I agree.
- As much, in the way that you do this.
It's like, its so negative everywhere.
- Everywhere.
- And it is a hard thing
to constantly avoid it.
- It's why I'm so passionate to like,
even when I don't wanna do it,
you know there's a part of me,
there's almost like a
sense of responsibility.
You know, you want something to happen you
gotta do it yourself, and so
if I wanna inspire people
to post more positivity.
Practical posi-
The reason you like it is
because you're an operator.
It's practical, it's not like
everything's gonna be okay.
- Yeah no, I love being creative.
Creating artistic things,
working with artistic people.
- Nice to meet you.
I think you're doing such
a great thing for kids.
- Thank you.
- I really do.
- Thank you for seeing it.
- I think you should create a curriculum,
that's required of every
single junior in high school.
- Thank you.
- I mean you are preaching.
- I am basically trying to do that
for free on Instagram.
- Right, well you're doing it.
- The one today, or yesterday, where
the kid wanted four-
he wanted four months off, I was going
oh my god, are you fucking- what a moron.
- Hugs, big hugs.
First of all thank you,
because I was so inspired
by your speech at
the last hall of flowers,
I went out and made a podcast.
Because you sat there
and said go make content.
- Make a fucking podcast.
- There's a thousand different ways,
but it was one way that went got it.
- That's what I'm trying
to figure out every day.
- Got it.
- Go do it, brother.
- That's a great game right there.
- Do you have any type of mentorships
or programs underneath you?
- No I'm just putting out,
so much fucking free content online.
- I appreciate that.
- That's my mentorship.
- People that don't know what
the fuck they're talking about.
- Yeah bro, I've (inaudible
words) by Ollie recently, man.
He's fucking dope man.
- He's the best dude, that's my guy.
That's my guy, yeah yeah.
What's up brother?
How are you?
- Why would you hire us?
- I remember.
- You wouldn't let us into your buildings.
- I said yes, I said yes.
- I know all about the-
- I was like I want half
your penthouse suite.
- I don't know if you saw, did you see
the Dwayne Wade video
we did for Budweiser,
and then I made everybody cry.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I wanna talk to you about that part,
as well, because I
think, it really matters
in a way that influencers
and people who choose
don't always see, because we could make
so much happen ourselves.
Anyway, there's things to talk about.
- Yeah, yeah. It was nice to meet you.
- Yeah man, congrats, really, honestly,
I'm very, very impressed
so far, I really am.
- I'll get back to New York soon.
- Okay and I'll be in SF in L.A.,
so we're gonna figure it out.
That's what's up bro, take care.
- How's it going man, how's it going?
- How are you Chris?
- So, how you doing?
- Really good.
- Yeah?
- How's the show been for you guys?
- Really good, yeah, like we've got like
you know, kind of a campaign theme going.
We got in a little trouble,
because we were wild posting everywhere.
- Its Gary! Hi Gary!
- Hello, how are you?
Never gets old.
You get anything accomplished?
- Well we're accomplishing
serving a lot of people,
a lot of-
(laughing)
- Get you across the
finish line, yeah yeah.
There is no behind.
Behind no longer exists.
Right, don't want to hurt your neck?
I've heard that content.
- Yes, looking back hurts-
- Looking back hurts your neck.
- That already sounds good.
Not exactly the same, it's not new eras.
But I'm feeling really good.
Feel like it's fun to
watch a place mature.
It reminds me a lot of like,
South by Southwest from like 2008 to 2009.
Obviously on a smaller scale but like
obviously the energy's a little different.
'Cause I'm kind of curating a talk.
But, yeah good.
Joe's here, looks great.
Joe and Phil look great.
So that's nice.
- I try.
- Glad they can stay alive longer.
Oh, they only have three seats.
What do we do?
Like we're unable to
adjust to this situation.
Cinnamon Cola?
Nobody, nobody, Derock, drinks
Cinnamon Cola better than me.
- Really taking it to the next level here.
- You're drinking soda too?
What's happening right now?
- I'm just trying shit.
I didn't love it.
- Ope, sorry.
- Here we go?
- Here we go.
(clapping)
- Did they just announce me?
Did he announce me, no?
- You'll go no.
(announcing)
(crowd cheers)
- By show of hands, how many people
were here for the keynote last year?
Very nice, bunch of new people,
so it's great to see so many new faces.
Literally, literally,
right before I took stage,
one of the things that
always fascinates people
when they get close to me,
is I do all my own social, right?
Like I posted the post
that I just posted on
Instagram right before I came on stage.
And it says something to the degree of,
you know, anything that
happened yesterday,
has no impact on tomorrow.
You have to let go,
that you were in for six years,
and that you were off the
market for nine months.
Once you do that, I promise you
you'll do what you did the first time
and you'll just execute,
and play tortoise versus hare.
When I started my .com,
wine.com got a 123 million
dollars in funding.
I had 37 thousand dollars
in marketing, right?
I just built, I just stayed patient.
It hurts when you think you perceive
that you had an advantage by being first
six years ago.
But you lost it by regulation,
and that part is the fucked up part.
Bro, do you know how many of these people
that are super well-funded
are gonna go directly
out of fucking business?
Do you know how many fake
entrepreneurs I met here today?
(audience applauding)
Do you know how many of
these well-funded companies
are gonna spend their money on dumb
fucking executions in marketing and events
and other dumb shit?
Just 'cause you have a lot of money
doesn't mean you're gonna spend it well.
What are you gonna do?
You're gonna do what you always did.
Slow and steady, execute,
build the brand,
bring value to the people that are
trying to put your
product in their stores.
Build awareness around it's brand.
The end.
Do not let outside forces dictate
anything that you're thinking about.
(clapping)
Patience.
I don't have any secret
fucking arsenal of apps.
You know, like I use all the same shit
everybody else does.
I just, it's what I fill
the platforms with is what matters.
Everybody starts with zero followers,
everybody's got the same
apps that everybody's on.
It's what you fill it with.
The biggest difference between me and the
far majority of the market,
is every time I put
out a piece of content,
I literally through my
brain, in my fucking soul,
think what's this gonna do for them?
99 percent of people when they post,
think about what's this gonna do for me.
That's the fucking game.
(clapping)
How many likes am I gonna get?
How many T-shirts am I gonna sell?
Who's gonna see this that's
gonna feel cool for me?
Everything's about me, me, me, me me.
Which is why everything seems the same.
Which is why every fucker
is sitting in a swan
in a pool in the Hamptons.
It's like, it's all the same shit.
Fucking flowers in the
fucking hair at Coachella.
Fucking gold fake fucking watches.
Jumping fences to take a photo,
at the fucking private plane place.
It's all the same shit.
It's me, me, me.
The second you don't think that way,
the second everything changes,
and growing up in restaurants
and retail stores,
where you serve,
is an incredible framework,
and I got lucky that I went
through those experiences
before this world came.
Because it became my framework,
and man I think everybody should work in
a restaurant or a store for two years.
It's a foundational advantage.
(clapping)
I really do.
I will, I wanna see the-
I knew it was hot.
But I didn't realize-
- If we had Instagram-
- Back then.
- A trillion followers.
- Hi, hi, how are you?
- Hey Gary what percentage
of operating would you-
- As much as I can afford,
like I, basically, I don't make money.
In my businesses when I'm running them.
Because I pour everything into brand,
because I'm building in perpetuity.
- Gary, hi I'm Ukrainian.
- (Ukrainian language)
- So, yeah can you sign me please?
- Yeah, of course.
- Thank you, I watch your videos,
I love your YouTube channel.
- Thank you bro, thank you so much.
- Gary, Jared Bersky, Wick and Mortar.
- How are you, good to see you bro.
Thanks for your question, thank you.
- It's so great to meet you.
I really appreciate it, you've
been such an inspiration-
- Thank you so much.
- For so many years.
And I'm gonna email you.
- Please, thank you.
- What's up Gary, my name's Ar,
I've been instagramming your content for a
very, very long time.
I'm like 24 and trying to build that.
I had a question for you really quick,
if you don't mind,
actually picture first, please.
- Yeah.
- Steady, consistency.
- Fucking I'm doing my
business tips of the day man.
- Good for you.
- And you're fucking,
and its helping people,
and I realized like don't
hold it close to the chest.
Just give it all away.
- Its not a secret.
- Just give it all away.
- You know its so powerful
to hear you say that.
When I started doing what I was doing,
it was so common for
people to be confused why
I was giving away my secrets.
And, you know, the younger crew,
they don't even know the world
that we kinda grew up in,
where like that information.
- I worked hard, I dug ditches.
- I get it, I get it.
- I worked every fucking crazy ass job.
- But it was so fun that
I got to say what I said.
There's so much abundance.
Of course.
- Hi Gary, you're the
reason I started a company.
- How are you?
I'm not investing a whole lot right now,
I think things are overpriced.
And I'm also very focused on Vaynor
and Green Screen, like the
things I own right now.
Yeah, you know like, its weird
what like I'm excited about.
Like, even like the
whole sports card thing,
like I just know, for fact.
That sports cards are about to go up
quite a bit in value,
and so like when somebody asks me,
"What do I do with my money?"
Like, I know exactly how to make
25 thousand into 100 thousand.
Buying Giannis, you know,
like Greek Freak rookie cards.
I can't say that about
a million other things.
So, it's crazy that those
things are coming out
of my mouth.
But it's 'cause I don't
wanna be vulnerable,
I don't want you to send
me an email and be like
dude you fucking told me, you know.
So like, I think that,
I think you've gotta go
where you're comfortable.
- Yeah that makes sense.
- And like, but here's what I will say,
for a lot of people listening,
I do think Facebook and Amazon,
as long as Bezos and Zucks
are running the companies,
are very good bets.
They may not always,
the government might get involved.
But if those humans are running shit,
like Vaynor will always be
successful if I'm the CEO.
It's no different than a good quarterback,
or a hall of fame basketball player.
People need to look at who's
running these companies
more so than what are they doing.
Because people adjust.
Mindy Grossman at Weight Watchers,
she's a fucking G.
Like I'm not super hyped on what
Weight Watchers is up to,
but like, she's a G, so like she might
go buy something that's
winning on Instagram, right now.
So, I'm a big believer on betting on
the CEO a lot of times,
and that's why I like those two bets.
Those things, keep-
- Now we got our dispersion license,
we got one brand going,
two in development,
crushing it, big inspiration, we're gonna
crush it even more.
- Thank you guys, good luck to you.
- I'm 29 and 33, I can't even imagine
- Babies, I'd fucking
rip my arm off to be 29.
- Can we take a picture with you?
- Yeah, yeah right?
Babies.
- Chatted with Joe, he invited me down.
Came back to Alaska, me and Zack,
we're just doing an overnight.
- I really loved having you guys.
- Thank you.
- It was fun.
Your energy's just the best.
It made me feel so nice.
- And after that fourties-
- Did you enjoy it?
- Like fucking unlock dude,
so many different strategies,
like influencer marketing,
personal assistant.
- The forties thing has
been like, such a hard run,
it's crazy.
- I can't wait to-
- And I sat on that for two ye-
- Nate does such a good job.
- He's such a-
he's the best.
I gotta go?
Okay. He's the best.
- Thank you so much, Gary.
- We'll see you in July for a meet up.
- Looking forward to it.
Take care.
Thank you.
- I actually wrote this book.
- That's fucking amazing bro.
- Wrote you a little
thank you note in there.
- Thank you bro, can't wait to read it on
the way to my airport.
- Yeah, I appreciate everything you-
- I want, I need the calls.
I need to like bounce sooner or later,
yeah what time is it?
One thing you should really look in to
is what Red Bull did when
they launched Red Bull.
They did such a hardcore
gorilla marketing campaign,
it was literally just,
hands on the ground.
Like one of the things
they did really smart,
was they crushed empty cans,
outside of the hottest clubs, and like-
- Oh I saw that.
- It was really smart,
so like what's amazing
about L.A. and Miami,
is like everyone's a sheep,
and like New York, it's just like,
if you could just make it-
- They all just copy each other.
- So, obviously, influencer marketing
works for that reason.
But, I would tell you to like
really have, whether it's interns,
or whether you guys hustled
to divide and conquer,
being there.
Like unabashedly just being in the fucking
right places, and like I think sampling.
I'm a big believer in sampling.
- What about LinkedIn for themes,
what do you think?
- Yeah I mean look,
I think LinkedIn's a
very interesting place
right now, because it's
super high, organic reach.
You don't need to run
ads, your content goes,
and it's like Facebook eight years ago.
I think look, I think for all of you,
because I know a lot of you
are listening right now,
the answer is yes to everything.
Like if you want to live a life where you
build a huge company, or like
you live on your terms.
The answer is yes to fucking everything.
LinkedIn, yep, podcast uh-huh.
Like standing outside of clubs and
handing them out, yep.
Influencer marketing, mhmm.
Hoodies, yep.
The answer's fucking yes to everything.
Pleasure good luck, nice meeting you.
- Gary, I'm straight up a Gary-
- I gotchu, I gotchu.
Do some free work.
- For them? Okay.
- Got it?
- I got it.
- It's the quickest was you get in.
Then people see the dope work,
and they're like yo how do I hire you?
Free work is always the answer,
but people feel like, it's like
"I'm not getting my worth",
or "I'm getting taken advantage of."
No you're not, you're getting exposure.
You're getting reps,
you're getting examples
to show everybody else
here that you know how to make video and-
I do free shit all the time.
Me! I believe in that shit.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- I love you, can you sign this for me?
Your face is on it.
- I see it.
- And can I get a picture?
- Where do you see future of re-
- Don't build on platforms
that can eliminate you.
Build the .com, siphon
attention from the platforms,
never be deleted again.
- Okay, definitely.
We're getting that text out there.
- Do you understand? Do you understand?
- One hundred percent.
- It's easy to get to a half
a billion when you leverage
platforms that have that kind of scale.
But, then you get deleted.
- Yeah you get disfunded, that's all we do
is just create more pages.
- Go in there, funnel
them into your world.
- Exactly.
- Do you understand?
- That's what we're
trying to build right now.
- That's awesome.
Got it, thank you bro.
Take care everyone, stay well.
- [Man] Hey Gary, last
thing I wanted to tell you.
I forget to tell you my
whole fucking brand dude,
I give 10 percent of my
profits back to charity.
- Thank you so much, have a great day.
- [Woman] You too.
- [Gary] Dude thank you so much man,
you fucking crushed for us.
- [Man] Oh yeah, for sure.
- [Gary] Thank you bro, I'm excited
to be a part of the same team.
The bottom ones, thanks Derrock.
Whether it's your .com,
whether it's your own podcast,
is unbelievably important.
And I highly recommend it to everybody,
in a very substantial way.
So, please give some real thought
to where you're building your content.
But most of all, is the
content in the best interest
of the other person on the line?
Or is it self serving?
To me that is the key,
of how to make contextual content,
king and queen in a 2020 world.
- Nailed it.
(laughing)
- Perfect, cut!
- Here do you mind if I
take a picture with you?
- Not at all.
- [Woman] Just hop on in!
- [Gary] Thank you so much for you help.
- [Woman] You just gotta deal with it.
- [Gary] This is, I love this.
- [Man] A beautiful car.
- Get in here Katie.
- [Man] One, two, smile, beautiful.
- Okay, but we want one
with you too, because-
- Yes David get in here.
- [Gary] Awesome.
- [Man] Thank you.
- [Gary] Thank you so much,
thank you so much, nice to meet you.
I love that shit so much more
than something that's-
- I'm Barney by the way.
- Barney, real pleasure.
Your shit was real.
By the way my answer was super real too.
Just, you know, I know it sucks dude.
- Yeah, we've been through the ringer man.
- Dude wine library was the on-,
because I was building such,
the biggest internet liquor store.
We were the only store that
wasn't able to be shipping
in so many states.
Literally, four thousand liquor stores
shipping in to Texas,
one can't in the whole country.
Mine.
I took a third of a day to like
cry to myself and be like,
Fuck this blows.
And then like what?
Like what?
- Twitter or email?
- Email.
It's far more-
- Can I steal it from
you if you don't mind?
- Yeah, it's Gary-
- What do you think
about Appalachians for-
for herb from like the NorCal area.
- I believe in that shit.
That is, that is where it's gonna go.
Terwa's gonna play out.
At Vayner, V-A-Y-N-E-R,
media.
- Got it.
Dot com?
- Yes sir.
- Okay you want me to take it for you?
- You got the car?
Thanks for your question.
(chatter)
- One, two, three, beautiful people.
- It's gonna carry weight,
it's gonna carry weight 'cause
it's how people, like the Terwa's,
like any agricultural product eventually
goes into the actual location of the soil.
It's the branding of the
soil that's gonna play out.
But, because the wine
industry already did it.
For this industry,
it'll be interesting to see where
like, does Napa play, is that true?
Like how did grapes act different?
Like, it's gonna play.
It's gonna play on the super premium.
Like what people don't understand yet,
is people are gonna spend real money on,
like people are gonna spend real money.
Like real money!
- Real money.
- Yeah, just like the way people,
like I remember having this discussion
20 years ago with somebody.
Like people are gonna
spend a thousand dollars
on a pair of sneaker,
and the guy laughed me
out of the fucking office.
And hit me up,
I mean hadn't talked
to the guy in 17 years,
he cold emailed me like five years ago.
He's like just, "You were right".
You know?
- That's a nice feeling.
- It's what I live for.
Literally everything that
comes out of my mouth,
is for that feeling.
Like that's what I think about,
how to be right.
- Yeah, you think outside of the box bro.
It's a beautiful thing.
- I appreciate it bro.
- Can we get one more picture?
- Yeah I'm going to catch a red eye.
Bye everyone, take care!
- Can we get one more picture?
- [Woman] You want me in it?
- Yeah.
- Of course.
- I thought you just said
you've got a boy crush.
- And a girl crush, take care!
Bye guys.
- You changed my life.
- Thank you bro.
- A long time ago-
- Take care.
See the thing is, when
you do the right thing.
Very nice things happen for you in return.
You just have to decide,
what's the ROI of your life.
Is it money?
Or is it admiration?
(music plays)